هل من سهل على عائله غربيه ان تنتقل للعيش
في الرياض سؤال يطرحه كبار المسؤولين
التنفيذيين في الشركات العالميه في ظل
موجه انتقال مقراتها الاقليميه الى
العاصمه السعوديه واخرا
سوره كريستيانو رونالدو مع ابنائه وشركته
جورجينا رودريغيز في الرياض تختزل الف
كلمه عن التحول الذي تعيش به المدينه
[موسيقى]
شخص لما ياتي هو وعائلته هذه السعوديه
ويعطي رسائل كثيره جدا من ناحيه التسويقيه
من ناحيه العمل الوطنيه من ناحيه انه انا
واهلي واطفالي سنعيش في هذا البلد سنوات
وهو مكان جميل ورائع
ومميز ان تعيش فيه كعب انه موسم الانتقالي
الى الرياض التي تشهد موجه افتتاحا
للمفردات الاقليميه لدرجه ان من الصعب ان
تجد مكتبا فارغا في اي من الابراج
المكتبيه الحديثه بحسب ما تشير شركه
الابحاث العقاريه
رونالدو يمثله رجل اعمال وهو عباره عن
علامه تسويقيه متنقله تراثقه في كل قطبه
او حركه فهو لديه نصف مليار متابع على
انستغرام
التي لديها 44 مليون متر فكيف تستفيد
السعوديه من وجود جماع في تعزيز علامتها
الوطن
[موسيقى]
من هذه الكفاءات هي تعزز من الصوره
النبطيه والصوره العلامه الوطنيه لانه لها
اثار اقتصاديه بمعنى لما اقول كلمه الصين
او اليابان الواحد ياتي المشاعر كثيره
بسبشن وقناعات تؤثر
في اشياء كثيره
[موسيقى]